hi guys and welcome to episode 2 of
let's play city skylines now in the last
episode I started working on this small
little suburb ish kind of town in the
middle of I have no idea where this
actually is that's kind of kind of
stupid it almost seems like it's in like
one of the eastern states of the United
States I have no idea really but yeah I
started working on that and today I'm
just going going to kind of do the same
follow these same kind of layouts that
I've been doing so far and I'm actually
quite happy about this I haven't really
had too many traffic problems with this
the basic idea is actually inspired by
many Dutch cities because the thing that
they've got going on very often is there
is a big road and which is in this case
in the shape of a four-lane road which
goes around the areas with which people
live in and then you're going to have a
couple of entrances just a couple and
from those entrances you get all of
these well I don't know really what to
call it but all of these curvy roads and
on all these curvy roads you've got
houses and everybody hates it in real
life because everybody gets lost in
cities like this which is yeah it is it
is an argument to say that why those
curvy roads everybody gets lost in them
you should probably have square roads
that's more practical but then again I
really like the look of curvy roads much
more I mean look at this this is this is
just beautiful especially with all those
trees and I know I should I I now know I
should watch out with placing all of
those trees because there is a limit to
the amount of trees who can place which
sentence me and but yeah there's no way
I can get around that but somebody said
it's about 250,000 and I'm sure that's
counting the trees that are already out
there but I'm sure I won't hit me
250,000 limits unless I start spamming
forests everywhere or I start buying 25
tiles which is something that you can't
do without a mod and I'm not sure if I'm
actually going to do that so I'm not
going to really worry about that I'm
still gonna place
trees like that because seriously what
what is the city without trees I don't
know it just makes the city look so much
better I can't stand to see cities
without trees and parks and stuff like
that and I've always been spamming it in
every single world every single game
ever
plate I think so yeah I'm really glad
that you can do it in a way that it does
in this game to the only thing that I
was thinking about though is the fact
that you place a tree down and
immediately you've got a huge tree it
doesn't have to grow or anything like
that I actually thought that maybe they
could have implemented that but then
again it's it's Leslie realistic but I'm
kind of happy that they did it in this
way because that means you don't have to
wait for your trees to grow and you can
instantly see how good it looks so it's
kind of I'm not really sure what I would
rather have so now and at this point I
got the roads with trees and I was very
very happy with that because roads
without trees are just no no it just
it's not as good the only the only thing
that I did see though is that if you
have a two-lane road with trees on the
sides you don't have parking spaces but
so far it seems that I haven't had any
problems with parking and also not with
traffic jams or anything like that and
of course this city is still very small
and I might definitely get some traffic
problems in the future
but with a system like this for the
residential areas as long as I keep them
low residential and I'm definitely going
to not place too much high residense
residential because I think that's
something you shouldn't do especially
considering the fact that you know the
city has only eight thousand pop even
more people living in it so why would I
even place big plots and stuff like that
I just I just kind of want to wait with
that until my city grows even bigger and
even then I am kind of going to place
them very sparsely because for one I
like the look of it more I don't want to
have big high buildings everywhere this
is not going to be a Manhattan kind of
went too well have sparse well basically
yeah that's going to be how I'm going to
do that and it also has a practical
reason though because if you're going to
place big flats like that especially if
all your roads and stuff I designed for
light residential land you're going to
have some traffic problems very likely
and I definitely want to avoid that too
so for multiple reasons I'm going to not
place too many high buildings but that
small little commercial area that I have
over here I
I've kind of assigned that as a future
growth area and I might actually remove
some commercial as soon as the demand
for that drops and actually replace it
with some dense residential so that's
going to be my kind of Manhattan ish
area over there and definitely a very
concentrated area as you can see but the
other thing is it's also connected by
three different four-lane roads so I
don't think I'm going to have to worry
about that too much
as you can see there is some congestion
on the industrial area kind of roads but
yeah that's something I'm going to fix
in the future because right now I don't
think it's too much of a problem you
definitely want to keep your trucks and
keep your normal cars on different roads
because as you can see if you have your
trucks with all their loads I have to go
to the industrial area and you also have
the people want to go to the homes and
same roads it start of it kind of starts
to become a chaos and that's definitely
something I want to avoid but right now
I don't have any land yet using which I
can make some highway connections that
are meant specifically for all the
trucks for the industry areas now this
little area is going to be a residential
area and how I'm placing some water now
down there but this area is kind of my
favorite area in the city so far I just
kind of liked the look of it with the
circle like that and stuff and it's all
light residential and it's just your
perfect suburb I suppose and I just like
laying out Road patterns like that it's
it's fun it works actually because you
have only one entrance I don't have too
many oh wait no this thing actually has
two entrances that's almost a lot but
you don't have too many crossings or
anything like that so not too much
traffic stuff going on and it looks
really nice and you actually get some
spare room for parks and trees and stuff
like that too so definitely really happy
about that
now at this point I think I had to play
cemeteries and this actually turned out
to be a very big problem that I did not
expect to have beforehand because as it
turned out I would have the hugest
problems with dead people in my city
because dead people are so annoying
seriously
I've always played these city building
games and always used to have
slight problems with the electricity or
whatever garbage but I never have I ever
had problems with dead people all over
my city and then as soon as one of the
cemeteries was for but I kind of didn't
notice because I was working on a new
area and then I zoomed out and bam there
were dead people everywhere and
abandoned buildings and speaking of
abandoned buildings it's kind of
something that I've seen so far that you
it's hard to avoid because even if you
don't have really big problems in your
city you're still gonna have a couple of
abandoned buildings but every time
you're gonna have to manually remove
those buildings so I am actually
thinking about getting that one mod
which automatically removes your
abandoned buildings for you because even
though to me it almost feels like
cheating if you're using a mod I kind of
don't want to have the abandoned people
about buildings in my city and having to
remove them every time it's kind of you
know it taking you away from the
gameplay that I really want to do and as
you can see I'm kind of doing some new
dress districts over here and kind of
filling up this one square the one thing
that I did want to try was to fill up
this main square as much as possible and
only then start buying more squares
around it I don't know what really was
my thought process behind this but I
kind of wanted to get this to work
before I actually moved on to other
areas and started building too big and
started getting into trouble with that
or something like that so I definitely
want to keep a constant growth of the
city but constant also means with no
ridiculous peaks of let's build an
entire new area which is going to be
this extremely big now one thing that I
didn't want to do and this is some kind
of future development because I'm not
going to do anything with this highway
yet but this highway is there so that in
the future if people want to get to the
other side of the river or the other
side of the city they're not going to
have to cross the city itself because I
do want to keep as much of the traffic
that I don't need to have in the city
out of the city and what this road is
hopefully also going to do is it's going
to you have to it's going to make the
people from the other highways from like
the north of the town go to the
industrial zone in the southern part
the town because that that industrial
zone is still kind of clogging up and
before I have any solutions this is
going to be my kind of solution at the
moment and but also a very future
investment because I want to avoid Road
problems in the future and I'm going to
leave out some areas so I can place more
highways and perhaps even a train at
some point one thing that I had that I
am very happy about though and I kind of
wanted to stop comparing this game to
Sim City but in subsidy many people
would always want to go to their work do
their industrial zone using the train
and that was kind of stupid and I'm glad
that you don't have to do that anymore
it's just you just have to get good Road
patterns and a good buzz line so I'm
really happy about that and oh god I had
some problems with this this little
highway crossing over here but yeah and
the next episode I am going to well work
in the city again what else could I do
so thanks for watching and I'll see you
in the next episode bye